Selam stands for sharing an affection
love and mercy and that's what we do in
Sharla specific specific at the time
that we live where Haley's been hate
it's being spread by the label given
freedom of speech and this sometimes
comes at the cost of innocent people
dying and we saw that Christchurch we
saw that in London where we're from
innocent people getting killed Muslim or
non-muslim and we want to put an end to
this and one of our objectives is to
deconstruct false narratives and
reconstruct pure minds and that's our
main objective and I just wanna thank
every single one of you guys for coming
you can check our web sites around the
world oh okay
inshallah were planning on setting up a
team in California this is a beautiful
country the raw sweet flavor absolutely
amazing and early in the team every time
[Applause]
thank you very much for that so first
we'll be introducing brother Mohammed
hey job is a debater and public speaker
who engages in discussions and polemics
on a wide variety of topics including
religion politics and society he
completed a politics degree and a
master's in the history in history from
Queen Mary University he has taught and
instructed courses on humanities and
languages in many contexts he has come
he has numeracy Jazz's and some Islamic
Sciences and his study and numerous
Islamic seminaries including the shim
plate the Institute which employs a
traditional Mauritian style of teaching
of the sacred sciences Edward Eddy
tabash is a constitutional lawyer in the
Los Angeles area he graduated from UCLA
in 1973 Magnum laude with a
bachelor's bachelor's degree in
political science he graduated from
Loyola Law School of Los Angeles in 1973
he is the son of an Orthodox rabbi from
Lithuania and an Auschwitz surviving
mother from Hungary after decades of
spiritual reflection and seeking he has
determined that the universe is natural
with no supernatural being or beings no
god or gods involved in the creation or
perpetuation of our existence he chairs
the board of directors of the center of
Inquirer transnational a worldwide
organization of secular humanists and
scientific sceptics he's also known for
his legal work and separation of church
and state cases in which we seek to
preserve the equality before the law of
both believers and non-believers he
promotes a secular society based in
science reason and inquiry maintaining
strong conviction in this he's an
integral leader to several associations
which exists to separate church and
state a part of his work and separation
of church and state has specifically
been in opposing Trump's Muslims ban and
mosh although they're both extremely
qualified and we're very
excited to have them both in this debate
and for this reason we would like to
also request a certain level of
boundaries and guidelines for the event
and shot to make sure that it goes as
smooth as possible for both of our
speakers and that we ask that everyone
be as respectful as possible to both of
our speakers by doing a number of few
things so we would like everyone to
please if possible please do not shout
heckle Boo screen cause any form of
ruckus against either speakers you know
to in order to respect their time their
knowledge and everything that they're
doing for us today if people are causing
issues unfortunately we will have to
have security escort you out in respect
for both of our speakers also another
request that we have is that if you
would like to clap please feel free to
but only after the speaker is completed
with their what they're saying simply
because there is a time frame that each
of them has to be able to get their
points across and we do not want to
disadvantage either speaker by limiting
the other speakers amount of time and
with that and said please do that go
okay thank you so much for coming thank
you everyone
I really appreciate it and then I will
be passing off our the microphone to our
moderator which is ID number was
[Applause]
hello everyone thank you for joining us
as I mentioned I will be moderating
moderating the debate we will start off
with opening statements each speaker
will have 20 minutes to give theirs and
we will begin with brother Mohammad a
jab Somali can what happens a light or a
kettle first of all I want to thank
every single one of you for coming down
here I want to thank the University and
of course I want to thank I did have a
she was a really prolific you know
formidable opponent and a very
experienced atheist opponent for many
years and so I'm very happy that all of
you are here today to proceed there's no
doubt that there is existence there is
no doubt that there is existence
existence is divided into two things
possible existence and necessary
existence possible existence is
existence that otherwise doesn't need to
exist and its existence that could be
arranged in any other way its existence
which is dependent for example I'm
wearing a blue blazer this is a possible
existence doesn't have to exist it could
be arranged in another way and it's
dependent upon materials that were
created used to create it necessary
existence on the other hand his
existence which is couldn't be any other
way
existence which could not be any other
way is independent self-sufficient and
could not be how of existence now the
main argument today is this there cannot
be a world with only possible existences
that is the main idea there cannot be a
world with only possible exists
why because I'm going to be using the
sport a little bit it is only possible
existences you would have dependent
things depending upon other dependent
things now this can be reasoned
physically ontologically and
cosmological this by itself it would
require something outside an independent
thing in order for that series to exist
now as safe it was an infinite series
we'll get to that in one flows now let's
use a cosmological example we have a
tree that's very beautiful trees here by
the way in California like for integrity
review that tree requires the Sun to
photosynthesize in order to exist I
think it's fair to say if the treatment
exists of the Sundin exists the tree
would know exists it's fair to say yes
so long as that the Sun is required or
so long as the tree exists the Sun will
exist even if that was for an infinite
amount of time
now the Sun itself is part of its own
order and its father's own sense now it
requires other things in order to exist
and the end of this what is required
once again is an independent thing
that's this independent thing can only
be one wait a minute why is that because
if there was more than one necessary
existence it wouldn't be a necessary
existence because it could be conceived
that it can be arranged
in another way and you can't have two
things which are independent because
which one is dependent on which
therefore whether you conceptualize this
ontological cosmologically what
materialism dualism idealism you must
conclude that what is required in order
for any existence to exist as an
independent thing that is one that is
always an existence why because it
wasn't in existence if it could be
conceived that this thing is not in
existence it wouldn't be necessary so
has to be eternal and it cannot be made
up of all parts why because anything
which is a compound is generated
anything that's made up of parts is
dependent on those parts that's point
number one and point number two if it
was a possible existence it is made up
of parts you can imagine those parts
being arranged in a different way
therefore it falls into the category of
possible existence to summarize you
require any independent thing outside of
the series of dependent things in motor
for any existence to exist this thing
must be one it cannot have parts it must
be immaterial income from well supposed
to be
it must be eternal now this is what the
quran says in his basic definition of
god for who Allah Allah say is God one
and only a lot of cement the one who's
independent self-sufficient everything
depends upon him and he depends upon
nothing let me yell it will emulate he
forgets not to nor is He begotten he is
the eternal one three eternal post
eternal well Amir could never put on a
hat and there is nothing like him he's
in material he's not composed two parts
he's in copra so you see this is the
onion if this argument is cracked I have
lost in the bay this is my main argument
everything goes back to this argument
which goes back to the basic definition
of God what must be presented is a
formulation whether it's a cosmological
one or an ontological one which shows us
how it's possible their only possible
existences can exist without the
independent if that's done I'm ready to
be an atheist today now the quran says
verse 35
i'm holy woman why are you shaking i'm
holly and what a semi-wet you'll out but
laid open or were they created from
nothing
who were they themselves the creators of
themselves did they create the heavens
and the earth certainly they have no
certainty saying that the atheistic
position is one of male speculation you
can never achieve certainty with atheism
why because in this logical disjunction
you have four options either the
universe came from nothing which is
impossible ontological
math mathematically and cosmologically
possible no one has argued this really
it's a weak argument I don't think my
interlocutor with his experience will go
there he's very prominent and very
experienced you won't go there and oh is
it
eternal can it be eternal well let's say
it is wait a minute what did you say did
you consider that yes no problem
even if it was a tunnel for the sake of
argument it is dependent or independent
you still have the problem here but my
interlocutors are naturally so he
believes in the beginning of the
universe so that's not a problem for us
what other option do we have
is it self created like my friend Tom
does also says is it possible for
something to exist an artist at the same
time he gives the example of a mother
giving birth to herself
is that possible not possible so the
other thing is it was put into existence
by something which had the ability to do
so now the question is what are the
attributes of that thing
which had the ability to put the
universe into existence how do we reason
this by inference we say well if I had
the ability to put the universe into
existence it must have power because
that is required for that kind of thing
it must have creative capacity it must
have knowledge it must have knowledge so
you see we start to have a formulation a
question now we have to ask is why is
the universe one way and not another way
it's conceivable for example you see you
have celestial spheres in the universe
they're rotating in one direction we can
conceive and imagine of the possibility
of all of the celestial spheres in the
universe going the other way for example
we can imagine that so why is the
universe one way rather than another way
I will tell you that the only rational
explanation for that is that there is an
external particular Iser of the universe
say that all more time that there must
be an external particular riser of the
universe to choose between different
options possible options because then
you have no explanation for why the
universe is one way rather than another
way you have to have an external sorting
agent you have to have an external
sorting agent that decides X rather than
Y otherwise the question will be to the
Atheist how can you prove on naturalism
or how can you explain on naturalism
that the universe is one way rather than
another way it's a very straightforward
question now here's the thing if we know
that there is an external sorting agent
this implies will of this agent and if
there was more than one will there would
be a chaotic universe as the process by
the other blemishes are low
along with FS and that vessel behind a
line of Bellagio Sifu if there was more
than one of them the universe would have
been corrupted they haven't in the earth
would have been corrupted chapter 21
verse 22 how because if there's more
than one will ultimately which one is
steering the ship there would be chaotic
order but what I'm also says about in
chapter 23 verse 91 if there was one
more than one Almighty they would have
outstripped one another attempted to
outstrip one another for power so in
otherwise you can't have more than one
of those things for those reasons as
well and this brings me to my third
point which is the argument of the
physical coherence of the universe which
is a Quranic argument because today
[Music]
honey bunny Lake and bustable far see
how over has he that chapter 67 verse 3
look at the universe look up in the sky
look at the sky look at the coherence of
the universe do you see any
inconsistencies look again when I said
wait a minute look again let me look let
me see
is there any inconsistencies now I
thought about this verse and this verse
is telling us that there is a uniformity
of nature a consistency of nature a
coherence of nature the fact that the
universe is uniform coherence it is not
known by science its presupposed by
science wait a minute what did you say
let me say one more time if you look
from self are any introductory guide to
the scientific method like you got here
on the illustrated guide to the
scientific method he said that the fact
that you have rationalized able actors
that can see the universe and see its
consistency means that there's a
presupposition of science and what is
that presupposition that science is
uniform that the universe is uniform
it's rationalizing our behind science
said in his letters to solve them he
said the most incomprehensible thing
about the universe is that it is
comprehendible so I'm not making a
fine-tuning argument today because we've
heard enough of that every atheist and
every what's this fine-tuning argument
the argument is look at the constants of
nature yes you have these constants
which one a Goldilocks zone of life
permitting range if there were any way
this way or that way they would not the
universe would not exist and life would
not be minimus like mutton with just six
numbers and he says n which is capital n
and number
talking about you know the natural
forces he says is a billion billion
billion
billion and had any zeroes been taken
away yes then that would have been the
universe would have been completely
different he is another letter that he
talks about the conversion of hydrogen
into helium he says that this conversion
is 0.007 had it been 0.006 or 0.08 we
would not exist this is that way rights
it's not why I'm writing I'm not
cosmologists right that's why your
rights that's an argument from
probability that's an interesting
argument I think the interesting thing
is that many people theists Anant in
there atheists accept the fine-tuning of
the universe Stephen Hawking's accepted
it Richard Dawkins accepted it so it's
not really an area of controversy my
argument is about the uniformity of
nature the coherence of nature which is
presupposed by the universe by the
wisest scientific method the question is
therefore on naturalism on naturalism
how can you account for the coherence of
the universe you can't say well the
universe just is like Bertrand Russell
said because that is a circular argument
frankly it's a cop-out I'm asking for an
external explanation we are rational
people we should be able to explain if
nationally if naturalism has the ability
to to give us these answers then surely
we should be entitled to such answers
now I've got five minutes left and I've
made my arguments to reiterate my main
argument today is the argument from
contingency and it's not one that
liveness formulated it's a different
kind of argument from contingency that
many Western people are not familiar
with
it's from our tradition and frankly the
main question is this the question is
how can you explain the world either
ontological or cosmological naturally
that only has
that's the question if you can prove it
you've tracked the other now I know I've
been watching these videos incredible
speaker and because he's a lawyer he's
got that charisma that if when you start
speaking I might have to run away
actually incredible speaking but I know
I have a feeling of what he's gonna talk
about and I think it's gonna be the
problem of evil right now Epicurus an
old Hellenistic philosopher he had the
logical form of the problem of evil and
the logical form as follows that if God
is omnipotent and all good then if he's
omnipotent why does he not stop the evil
if he's all good then how come evil
exists the answer our question is as
follows
I'm going to give it to you right now
God is not just those two things he's
also also all-wise so in order for the
problem of evil from an Islamic
traditions perspective to be unlocked or
to make sense for a logical perspective
you have to show logically or
naturalistically or cosmologically or
mathematically or inductively
objectively any way possible
how how evil the existence of evil
contradicts the divine wisdom that's how
it goes
if we don't believe in a God with three
attributes goodness or two attribution
and omnipotence only that's not the god
we believe it so you have to show
otherwise it's an emotional argument now
the other thing he talks about is the
divine highness
why is God hidden from us now we believe
in the fifth as Muslims the immediate
knowledge of God the intuitive knowledge
of God and by the way this is the Muslim
specific belief we believe that we are
born believing in God we have the
immediate knowledge of God and that
society trains us away from that
knowledge of God so the Quran for
instance or the prophets come to
reinforce what we already knew prime
moodily if you like prime modelling from
a psycho spiritual perspective so God is
not hiding in fact he's reminding us and
Frances oma could never al Davina hat
tena basarat' sulla if an atheist dies
as an atheist and according to us if he
dies an atheist is not worth the message
of Islam he does not go to hell straight
away because since I believe so God is
not hiding according to us so these are
the two things I'm anticipating he's
going to be raising up some pre-empting
it and finally what I want to say and
we'll talk about this by the way the
Fatah the immediate knowledge of God
because there is empirical evidence of
that by the way Justin Barrett made an
interesting has many interesting books
on this he says that there is a there is
a divine receptivity to God and he done
you know studies with children
cross-culturally and found that children
naturally believe in God so atheism on
this idea is a social construct atheism
was a cultural construct so finally I
want to say that the Quran promises us
in Chapter number forty-one that Allah
will show us all the way in other words
his science he says by the blemish on
him January 17 hygiena philosophy
who seemed hot away and alone had a an
alum and now we'll have that we will
certainly show them our signs in the
horizons and in themselves until it's
made patently clear that this is the
truth
I hope today we can be as sincere as
possible and be open to this and I hope
now that we go back to that question of
how they can be only possible existences
I leave it to
[Applause]
is there some other mic I'm supposed to
be okay good evening everybody I want to
thank the Muslim Student Association for
putting on this debate and I want to
thank Mohammed for debating me I will
respond to his arguments in my rebuttal
but I will now present my positive
arguments for why it is more likely than
not that the evidence in our physical
universe clearly makes it so that a
supernatural conscious personal being
that is an Allgood all-knowing and
all-powerful deity the standard-issue
god of Judaism Christianity and Islam
does not exist argument won the argument
that from the way our world operates it
is much more likely that there is
nothing beyond the physical the evidence
shows that it is much more likely that
the universe is not impacted by any
invisible realms or by intentional
actions by immaterial beings the history
of scientific discovery has shown that
whenever we attributed phenomena to
paranormal creatures or gods further
examination showed such beings did not
cause what was happening we learned that
lightning is not caused by an angry god
or gods diseases are not caused by evil
spirits and by germs and demonic
possession has nothing to do with mental
illness as humanity has gone forward
natural explanations have always evicted
previously believed supernatural ones it
has never been the other way around
there's no verifiable evidence of
anything supernatural which there should
be if the supernatural existed since we
have no background information of
supernatural beings or events there is a
very low prior probability of them this
means that for instance if we were to
use Bayes probability theory we would be
predicting only natural explanations for
phenomena though we have never seen a
quark we know that the category of
subatomic particles particles do exist
evidence for the existence of
quartz has been steadily increasing one
indication of the soundness of the quark
model is its success in predicting the
outcome of high-energy collisions of an
electron and positron there are no such
equivalent empirically verifiable
indications of God's existence so we
cannot infer the supernatural from a
mere observation of the natural number
two the argument from the non occurrence
of miracles claims of miracles have the
initial problem of bearing witness
against themselves since by their very
content they are violations of the laws
of nature that are not supposed to be
violated all the supposed miracles that
are claimed to verify God's intervention
and human affairs allegedly took place
in a pre-scientific era
why don't we moderns have the same
opportunity to observe these miracles
today no verifiable events in today's
world correspond to the types of
miracles that monotheistic religions
claim happened in ancient times thus the
probability that a miracle happened
regardless of which religion makes the
claim will always be lower than the
probability that a miracle has not
occurred number three the argument from
the dependents of conscious minds on a
physical body and brain there is
overwhelming evidence that conscious
thought and awareness cannot occur
without a functioning physical brain
with operative cortical neurons and
synapses believing in a disembodied
super intelligence and in life after
death creates a serious dilemma if even
Alzheimer's disease can destroy
conscious awareness how can that very
same conscious awareness survive the
destruction of the entire body and brain
at death this would entail believing
that if certain portions of our physical
brains are damaged we lose the awareness
contained in those portions but if you
destroy the entire brain by death your
awareness will somehow reappear fully
intact in some immaterial form highly
unlikely if consciousness could survive
independently of the brain diseases
brain injuries and anesthetics would not
eclipse consciousness like they do since
the evidence shows there is no conscious
self-awareness or thought without a
functional brain with operative cortical
neurons and synapses
we cannot be expected to believe in any
God that is supposed to have a
disembodied thinking mind number four
the argument from evolution though many
theists believe in evolution because of
its sloppiness and trial and error
features evolution by natural selection
is more likely if there is no God more
than 99% of all species that have ever
existed are now extinct this is wasteful
we have useless components in our bodies
that indeed do more harm than good like
the appendix known to most of us only
when it's about to burst evolution by
natural selection is established by the
weight of the evidence for instance
there is a 100% match of DNA sequences
in the pseudogene region of beta globin
that is proof that humans and gorillas
had a common ancestor number 5 as
Mohammad predicted in his prophetic
wisdom the argument from evil the
evidential argument from evil God can
make whatever he wants happen and
prevent anything he doesn't want from
occurring so why are there holocaust
extremely dangerous and violent people
horrible diseases extreme poverty and
destructive natural disasters if we
humans need discipline we could benefit
from a military style training camp not
a concentration camp there was no
benefit for my mother's having been in
Auschwitz
another example malaria is a terrible
disease there is a gene though that
provides an effective defense against
malaria
it works by destroying any red
corpuscles that have been occupied by
any of the types of parasitic protozoans
that cause malaria but if one has
inherited this gene from both parents it
also causes sickle cell anemia why did
God have to set it up this way or allow
it to work
way to attempt to justify or explain the
horrendous evil and suffering in the
world the theist must be able to show
that God even with unlimited power could
not have prevented an even greater evil
but for the horrible evil and suffering
he actually created or allowed or with
unlimited power God could not have
brought about a very great good but for
the horrible evil and suffering God
actually created or allowed here the
theist must also be able to show that
the very great good that could not but
for this horrible evil and suffering
take place was indeed such a great good
as to morally justify subjecting the
victims to the agonizing pain they have
to endure if we take the concept of
God's omnipotence seriously this is a
very high burden for a supposedly
omnipotent being to meet the argument
number six from divine hiddenness a God
that wants us to know that this God
exists and wants a relationship with us
would not withhold evidence of the
divine existence and would understand
just what evidence many of us would need
in order to be able to believe if God
exists and created me God knows my mind
it knows that right now I couldn't
believe in God regardless how much I
wanted to just like I couldn't believe
in space alien visitations to earth
because of the absence of any evidence
showing these things to be true God's
not being forthcoming with the evidence
that would enable me to believe that God
exists while knowing that I can't
believe in the absence of such evidence
is more consistent with God's
non-existence than with the existence of
a God that wants me to know him/her or
it if your mother told you that your
father whom you've never met or spoken
to loves you Mary very much and wants a
father child relationship with you but
just has been too busy to ever come to
see you ever since you were born let's
say around your 18th birthday
you would probably conclude that your
dad really doesn't want a relationship
with you we can actually see the reality
of human fathers on a daily basis so
even if the dad and the above scenario
is always absent we can believe he
exists we don't have the
evidence that a God exists so if we are
told there is a God who loves us and
wants relationship with us but that God
never provides us with direct evidence
that it exists when such an all-powerful
God could easily provide that direct
evidence we are justified in doubting
the existence of that God and doubting
the desire of any such God to want a
relationship with us divine hip nasaw so
further z' the argument from evil if God
exists such a being would know that
unanswered questions about why there is
so much evil and suffering prevent many
of us from believing in such a God we
have a right to expect that a perfectly
good God would not allow such horrendous
evil and suffering without morally
sufficient reasons if we are not told
what those morally sufficient reasons
are then it is more probable that a
perfectly good God that wants to be
believed in and worship does not exist
six point one the argument from
religious confusion a subset of divine
hiddenness there is so much a great
disagreement over which religion is true
and even if over which branch of a given
religion is true if God exists and wants
us to know its will and follow divine
decrees we are justified in expecting
that this deity would not allow so much
confusion over who that God is what that
God wants us to believe in and what that
God wants us to do the presence of such
rampant confusion is more likely if a
God that wants us to know its will does
not exist so Catholics believe that when
the Pope speaks ex cathedra he's
infallible Protestants reject the
concept of a pope if only one of these
is true God should make clear to
Christians which one it is Sunni and
Shiite Muslims began to disagree over
whether Muhammad's successors should be
chosen by qualifications alone or need
to have a direct bloodline to Mohammed
Shiites believe that the 12th Imam in
the 10th century was taken into hiding
by God in a process called occultation
and will return at the end of time in a
full messianic
chasity to facilitate the final and full
understanding of the quran and the
prophets message Sunnis do not accept
this now even though the Sunnis and
Shiites share the Quran they have
different versions of the hadith which
are very important to Islamic
interpretation of the deeds and
traditions of the Prophet so if one of
these is true and the other is false God
should make clear to Muslims which one
it is
now the other also derived from divine
hiddenness argument from unreliable
revelations and translations from
defects and errors in the Bible and the
Quran if God exists we are justified and
expecting to discard will provide us
with a reliable revelation if there are
problems with the revelation then it's
more consistent with the God that is not
perfect both the Bible and Quran talk
clearly about male dominion over women
Genesis 3:16 says and thy desire shall
be to thy husband and he shall rule over
the surah 434 pick fault says men are in
charge of women because Allah hath made
the one of them excel the other
well we modern humans have learned that
there is no reason for men to be in
charge of women because women are the
intellectual and moral equals of men so
this itself this itself shows that both
the Bible and the Quran are incorrect
insofar as they vest the man with more
power
over the woman than the woman is vested
over the man also both the Bible and the
Quran talk about Hell eternally for
those who don't believe in the religion
each revelation is promoting well they
can't both be true it can't be true that
you'll go to hell forever if you are not
a Christian and you'll go to hell
forever if you're not a Muslim so if in
fact there is a God that bases our
eternity on
whether we choose Christianity or Islam
then that God should tell us which one
and not let us make the honest and
sincere mistake of picking the wrong one
and falling through the trap door into
eternal horror so the very fact that God
doesn't make this clear to us and give
us a clear choice is more consistent
with there not being a god that wants us
to find the truth now
also if Islam is true those of us who do
not speak Arabic and those of us who
can't read the Quran in its original
should be given a clear unambiguous
translation which is the functional
equivalent of Arabic or God should have
revealed the Quran in every major
language Muhammad Pickthall was one of
the most prominent translators of the
Quran into English in the 20th century
and in his translators forward it's a
direct quote the Quran cannot be
translated every effort has been made to
choose befitting language but the result
is not the glorious quran it can never
take the place of the quran in arabic
but then if god wants me to be a muslim
god should provide me with the proper
translation so i don't make any errors
now another argument from divine
hiddenness a subset is the argument for
moral confusion so many people acting in
good faith even members of the same
religion disagree about what is right
and what is wrong in a bewildering
variety of situations both the Bible and
the Quran condemned gay sex but most of
us know gay couples and our reason and
experience tell us that same-sex
relationships are no worse than
heterosexual relationships just like our
reason and experience tell us there's no
reason for men to be in charge of women
or rule over women as opposed to women
being
in charge of men and ruling over men so
if either or both the Koran and the
Bible were infallibly true and in errant
they wouldn't say these things argument
7 argument from scale or the argument
from human insignificance 68 percent of
the universe is dark energy 27 percent
is dark matter so a scant 5% of the
universe is even conceptually accessible
by us of that 5% virtually all of it is
comprised of empty space which is
instantly lethal to human beings so 99
point 35 nines of the universe is
basically off-limits to humans our
galaxy contains around 300 billion stars
our galaxy is one of 100 billion
galaxies in the observable universe and
we have no access to any of this
mathematically we are just one part in a
hundred followed by 39 zeroes of the
universe there are 20 septillion planets
in the universe that's 20 followed by 24
zeroes why would God need such a
literally astronomical number of excess
planets that we are the core of God's
creation and concern the universe is
13.7 billion years old the earth is 4.6
billion years old
we humans have been around for maybe
200,000 years if we are at the center of
creation and of God's concern why did
God wait 13.7 billion years for us to
appear an all-powerful engineer would
not have needed to suffer this kind of
inefficiency remember we are speaking of
a God that's supposed to be all-powerful
argument number eight the argument
against the existence of a transcendent
person a person is by very definition of
being who thinks and performs actions
and that in turn requires being in time
so how could God have deliberately
created anything if there wasn't an
environment of time and space in which
to operate sequentially so a could cause
be if the theist says that God exists in
and functions and some unknowable
metaphysical time
which of course there's no proof than
the theist is conceding that God is not
completely transcendent since God
operates in some nebulous context which
corresponds to time a being out that is
outside space and time is not working
within a framework in which anything can
be caused by anything else so we can see
that the overwhelming weight of the
evidence in our physical universe makes
the predictive power of atheism much
stronger than that of theism we see for
instance that the universe is not
perfect most of it is lethal we also see
that within 5 billion years the Sun will
burn out which means the earth will seek
to exist I don't see much perfection in
that so probabilistically taking the
totality of the evidence it's far more
likely than not that we live in a
natural not a supernatural universe and
that an all-powerful Allgood all-knowing
self conscious God does not exist thank
you
thank you so much for both of our
speakers that the next section will be
the rebuttal section each speaker will
have ten minutes to counter the other
speakers argument that was presented
during the open state opening statement
we will begin with Muhammad a jab and
then Edward tabash so on
I'll begin with everyone's choir all
right so I would made a points a
arguments I'm going to respond to each
and every sing one of them the first one
the verifiable evidence of something
which is supernatural which leads to the
second point which is they're not
evidence of miracle I'm gonna prove
today that Edward believes in miracles
what did you say let me say again
Edward believes in miracles what is a
miracle according to Edward and
according to David Hume is a violation
of the laws of nature is a violation of
the laws of nature what is a miracle
something which goes outside the five
senses which can't be really detected by
science because naturalism according to
the Oxford concise companion is or
philosophy is something which can only
be seen by science the response
[Music]
wah wah Miku is MIA possibly Navi he
says they say to us
they say he's strict structured example
and they say who's gonna raise the tents
when it becomes dust the one who gave
him life the first time now let's think
of this have we ever seen the transition
from chemistry to biology no this is
referred to as a bo genesis yes when
chemistry becomes biology every study of
biology presupposes this because if
there's no such thing as a movement from
chemistry topology they cannot be
biology therefore the dead became the
living have you seen that no have you
sensed that no is it scientific no do
you believe me yes it's a miracle
just like Jesus raising the bed it's a
miracle just like the day of
resurrection
it's a miracle so just as all those
things will happen the Quran says you
can believe in all of that its premise
on the movement for nonliving chemistry
to a biology you believe in it we all
believe in miracles if that is how its
defined and that's how you define it
number three the dependence of conscious
minds on the brain which is a
philosophical discussion frankly Raymond
Tallis who wrote a book called aping
mankind he's a neuroscientist he asked a
question if consciousness is in the
brain where is it in the brain what's
the natural explanation for where
consciousness is in the brain really
frankly the idea that you can lose
consciousness through an aesthetic and
then be in - self consciousness is
refuted by dreams the existence of
dreams
you know I closed my eyes you know why
see how can you explain dreams this is
the problem of her consciousness the
hard problem of consciousness you can't
bypass the academics this is something
that philosophers has been talking about
since time began number four
that the argument for evolution
evolution doesn't contradict theism but
which evolution are we talking about
Darwinian evolution after the 1960s one
thing will refute this the problem of
induction science has the problem of the
relatedness of induction interpretation
all of these things you can't say that
it's definite and he didn't say that he
was careful in his wording says most
likely but that could be reformulated if
new data is found it could be
reinterpreted it has to be interpreted
in fact there's more likelihood that our
evolutionary conceptions will change so
you can't really use this as an argument
the arguments from evil what is evil
here's the thing ladies and gentlemen on
naturalism evil does not exist construct
look at the works of Bertrand Russell of
Nietzsche post modernists even Richard
Dawkins in the blind watchmaker he says
there's no such thing as good there's no
such thing as evil it's all business
indifference that's what he says why
because on naturalism
you cannot put morality under a
microscope there's no way of
ascertaining that there is any morals or
naturalism there is no objective
morality why even are you talking about
for the sake of argument I say okay evil
this is what we said it's not
incompatible with wisdom of God the
Quran says again Oh le halal no Delhi
Italian luminous an one he's the one who
has created life and death to see which
one of you is best in these if there was
no evil that would be no test if there
would be no evil there would be no free
will
what's the point of life then what is
the purpose of this
Oh whatever wakame shuffle you and ye
fitna ye lay inert or John everyone's
gonna die nonsense wait a minute
everyone's gonna die I'm gonna die
Eddie's gonna die you're gonna die and
we will test you with good and evil as a
as a test and then you'll come back to
us it's a test without evil the remote
test next divine luminous we've already
covered this v Allah
we're all born with the predisposition
of God there is evidence for this poor
blue
Justin Barrett many people have already
said we have seen we have analyzed
empirical evidence of children how they
what is their natural instinct they is
mentioned just embarrasses they have a
natural receptivity they has a natural
receptivity to divine to the divine and
non anthropomorphic God not Jesus not
Buddha they have a net we have natural
inclination to God and the mass
reinforced by the prophets that's the
Islamic narrative the prophets came to
remind us of what we already knew it
says that the Quran is a reminder just
like if you were separated from your
parents or your mother and then you're
reunited with a she is by natural
instinct and the same thing with God so
we talked about divine from confusion or
so unreliable revelations I grew at this
point there are unreliable revelations
but I would want to see how that is the
case with the Quran there was no
argument there
chapter 4 verse 34 bad translation man
in charge of woman there's only one
translation I think or two it's men are
maintained as and protectors of women
and frankly if you didn't believe this
you wouldn't draft men to the army in
America men protect women and they have
done so it's not saying that they are
better than them the Quran the Prophet
sent in the money Sarah Pfeiffer Rogell
we're not equal to women so I mean the
Quran says
in in the y alegría hominid me come in
second and almost about to come about
that god does not let to waste any
action of a man or woman both but
anyways go back to the idea of natural
selection or natural selection the
patriarchy on feminism is justified
because if men can dominate women that's
a natural thing what's the problem or
naturalism
how can he justify feminism second wave
feminism or naturalism that's an
impossibility you cannot do it why not
third wave feminism why not the works of
Judith Butler why not please Siri why
not LGBT wants to be second wave equal
the Eurocentric understanding of
equality how does that natural natural
because want to see how he
mechanistically shows us that hell
eternity what both of us can't be
Muslims and Christians can be in a both
right the right about that but listen
solve any issue doesn't create any
problem the translation problem only one
way to understand the language there's a
translation problem with mathematics is
mathematics false therefore it's a
language if that translatable thing it
becomes false because of its content and
has to be translated than mathematics is
false
more confusion I mean yes there's more
confusion but just because there's
controversy of something it doesn't make
you false as a fallacy Hagen from scale
says ninety-nine quizzes 99.9 percent of
the universe is not suitable to human
life he's made the fine-tuning argument
for me and we we're on the 0.01 so why
is there possibility of that real I
agree with you a transcendent person a
transcendent person he defines person in
a certain way he says well God controls
tiny space simple as that
I mean it's not really an argument and I
think I've got a minute left I forgot
man left well well you know
here's the thing guys don't be swayed by
the red herring the red herring is a
moral red herring the Koran says this
about mended look here's the thing on
naturalism no one is born equal yes why
because actually liberalism is an
outgrowth of something which is called
the state of nature it's a fictitious
mythological construct which John Locke
and Thomas Hobbes wrong in their books
it's not scientific we came out of the
state a state of nature and we became
one
we became connected socially
contractually into the same this saw the
whole of liberalism and human rights by
extension is a myth it's a little mini
showing on naturalism how liberalism is
true how we are all born equal in fact
I'm told you know your average high
we're all different on naturalism were
all different
[Applause]
Mohamad initially said that his main
point tonight was the argument from
contingency the problem is to say that
there must be a necessary being for
everything that is contingent requires
that the necessary contingent situation
plays out in an environment with cause
and effect and yet Mohammed has always
said that the universe had a beginning
and there was nothing before and that
God created the universe out of nothing
here is the problem you cannot analogize
from cause-and-effect and necessary and
contingent beings from within time and
space as opposed to the very coming into
being of time and space in the first
place if in fact the Big Bang as is most
likely nothing preceded it there was no
time and space you can have no cause and
effect and we can't even speak of cause
and effect because there was no
environment for a to cause B now with
respect to the notion of a necessary and
contingent being there is a problem with
the concept of a necessary being the
problem is that a necessary fact cannot
explain a contingent fact without
introducing a new contingent fact in
need of explanation now let's see why
this is so if a necessary fact cannot
explain a contingent fact except by in
tailing it because any fact entailed by
necessary fact must itself be necessary
however the necessary fact does not
entail the contingent fact then the
explanatory connection it has to the
contingent fact must be a contingent one
which introduces a new contingent fact
in need of explanation and if the
offender of the argument replies that
this new contingent fact can also
explain by the necessary fact then the
same reasoning will apply introducing
yet another new contingent fact in need
of explanation
and so ad infinitum but the whole reason
for introducing necessary fact in the
first place was to avoid an infinite
regress of explanations now Mohammed
said that we cannot even call something
evil unless we have a moral foundation
implying that objective moral values can
only exist with a supernatural being but
he doesn't explain what the connection
is for instance I've shown you in the
Bible and the Quran where though
Muhammad resisted men are supposed to be
in charge of women I've showed you in
both the Bible and the Quran where
people are sent to hell forever
for not just choosing the right
respective religion to say that we are
in no position to judge whether God's
doing that is right or wrong
totally eclipses human reason and
there's another problem with that to say
objective moral values depend on God you
have to ask is something good just
because God says it is then it's
arbitrary and even sending sincere
people to hell forever for not believing
in the right religion would be ok just
as God said it or they always tell us to
do what is good but the standard of the
good is independent of God then it means
that objective moral values exist
without being created by God by God
recognizes them and you can't get out of
it by saying well no the good comes from
God's perfect nature because we don't
see that perfect nature now as far as
the dependence of consciousness on the
physical brain is concerned nothing
mental happens without anything physical
happening there is no thought or
awareness that comes into the human
brain without a physical event in the
brain this is very very important again
if consciousness could exist apart from
the brain
then diseases and anesthetics wouldn't
eclipse consciousness now he talks about
the coherence of the universe and he
thinks the argument from scale is not a
problem but it certainly is if as a
somebody who believes in the Quran
because he quotes the Quran a lot he
believes in a God for whom humans is
central in concern then why all these
excess septillion x' of planets also if
in fact the universe is so perfectly put
together why will the star upon which we
depend the Sun burn out in a very short
span of time and then after that we will
die because the earth will no longer
have the Sun and there can't be life on
Earth without the Sun also with respect
to the whole concept of naturalism
Muhammed can't just like I saw in one of
his tapes he tried to say that we can
infer the existence of God from the
functioning of the universe just like we
can infer the existence of gravity from
the way gravity operates but you see
definitionally gravity as I dropped
something it hits the floor or hits the
table but that doesn't show that there
is a supernatural source behind it in
terms of the laws of nature the
constants and the fine-tuning as far as
that's concerned well the laws of
physics as they appear cannot be
violated but if they are and if you
change one constant and the other
studies have shown you can still have
light for instance there was a study
that showed that you can eliminate the
weak nuclear force one of the four
forces and stars could still form ifs
could form and explode becoming
supernovae then planets could still come
about we've also seen that there is a
argument from cosmic inflation which has
demonstrated the Cosmic Microwave
Background and the way inflation works
with quantum mechanics that are could be
a multiverse numbers and numbers of
individual universes each with their own
pockets of different physical laws this
hasn't been established by proof but yet
it is a better argument than theism
because it has a Basics in physics and
it has natural laws that are explainable
the other thing that Muhammad has not
yet addressed is he would have to admit
that in 99% of all instances in human
technological process when science has
looked for an answer it has found a
natural answer so what would be those
instances that differentiate the need
for a natural answer to a supernatural
one in other words if we look at a cell
or a bacteria the way it behaves natural
explanation but we look at something
else and our answer is only God did it
there's a world of difference between
looking at the fact that planets revolve
around the Sun and that stars don't fall
out of the sky except when they explode
as supernovae and going outside right
now and seeing the constellations saying
Eddie and Muhammad you're both wrong you
better become Mormons there's a world of
difference between those two that would
be a supernatural event also Muhammad
has never been able to and I don't blame
them because no one can can show how if
in fact consciousness depends on a
physical brain how the greatest
intelligence in the universe can exist
and think and function without a
physical brain how can there be a God
that doesn't have cortical neurons and
synapses how does God think when all the
evidence shows that the occurrence of
thought requires cortical neurons and
synapses and also if God is outside of
space and time God cannot be a
personal being because by very
definition a personal being is defined
as something within space and time that
has limits
so again naturalism prevails over
supernaturalism by the weight of the
evidence and we can see that there has
never been any verified supernatural
occurrences and we have seen no evidence
of any mental process that can exist in
a disembodied state so the evidence to
date makes it more likely than not the
universe is natural not supernatural and
there is no God thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much to both of the
debaters both brother Muhammad a job and
Edward tabash so the next session would
be the question and answer between them
both however just because of the timing
and because now that it has come in
hello everyone thank you for joining us
back again this next section will be the
cross questioning section the way this
will work is those speakers will be at
the podium we will begin with Muhammad
hijab
he will ask a question you'll have one
minute to formulate the question and
wording you'll have two minutes to
answer this will continue until Muhammad
has been able to ask three questions
then we will alternate that means Edward
will ask three questions again each
question will be one minute each and
each answer this time by Muhammad will
be two minutes each so if I can ask both
Edward and Muhammad to join me at the
podium or go to the podium thank you if
you like a good wet into the just one
mic okay okay
Frank Frank Sinatra and Egon Martin from
1950 I'm the only one old enough to know
that joke okay okay I was gonna say that
you touched upon morality and I think is
an important thing to talk about because
I have lots of intrigue to hear your
answer to the particularly this
particular question on naturalism what
scientific explanation can you provide
for the existence or the objectivity of
morality the answer is that I can give a
better explanation for morality on
atheism that on theism even if it's not
a perfect answer because on theism
someone looks into a book and without
any proof that God really said it saying
well God said it therefore it must be
true regardless of what we think about
it just because God said it which
eclipses human reason on atheism what we
do is we wrestle it out with our
reasoning and there are a whole avenue
of areas by which we can assess morality
and even if they're not perfect they're
more reliable than believing in a deity
for instance there's consequentialism
the consequences of actions being good
or bad there is the notion that our
moral values stem from our biological
nature see the problem was saying that
morality comes from God is circular
because what you're doing is you are
positing a God so you can have objective
moral values that you can then use to
try to show that that God exists and
that's is not a valid form of argument
which is
something else on that atheistic
naturalism what scientific experiment
would you conduct those up or could you
refer to that tells us about the
existence of mathematics how can you
prove mathematics through science is
very easy we prove mathematics
empirically for instance two of one
object and two of another object equals
four but what's important about that is
that is so axiomatic that it couldn't be
altered for instance God couldn't appear
right now and say by divine Fiat there
are three debaters standing at the
podium not two and so mathematics and
logic are actually arguments against the
supernatural because they show laws of
logic and laws of mathematics that
cannot be altered you see conceptually
it doesn't even work
to say God could make 2m 2 equals 5 and
so on naturalism we discover the laws of
nature we don't invent them and they're
not prescribed by anybody so for
instance we discovered the laws of
geometry nobody invented them we
discovered the workings of calculus we
discovered the laws of engineering
nobody invented it that if we put up a
building this way it'll collapse if we
put up a building the other way it will
collapse we discovered it just like we
discover what medicines work so
therefore on naturalism we would expect
that these laws could not be altered by
anyone a god or any other type of being
so it would be very difficult to put it
together but on this point of once again
on naturalism I have another question
because we made mention of some
historical events now obviously we both
have believed in parts of history for
example we believe in you know the slave
trade you believe in the Holocaust we
believe in you know things that have
happened even all the way back to the
prehistoric age if witness testimony
which is what is required for history to
take place for example your mother's
history of what happened to her or
whatever it may be how can you how can
you legitimize witness testimony or
naturalism and if it's not legitimized
does that mean that we can deny things
like slavery the Holocaust well you see
the answer to that is by empirical
evidence we know that certain things can
happen if I said that I flew here on an
airplane today nobody would question it
if I said I just flap my arms and flew
here bodily you would question it if I
told you that somebody crossed a river
to get to the other side you would
accept it if I told you that somebody
was levitated from one side of the river
to the other you wouldn't
this shows that we have an in-built
already recognition through logic and
reason and experience of understanding
eyewitness events that are within the
realm of what we know to be probable and
those which are not if I said that
somebody drove me here tonight for the
debate in a car you would believe me if
I said space aliens picked me up in an
interstellar spacecraft and brought me
here you wouldn't believe me so we
shouldn't shy away from the common sense
experience that already helps us
distinguish the natural from the
supernatural okay Mohammed I'm handing
you of five different translations of
surah 434 each one talks about men being
in charge of women
and there's nothing corresponding about
women being in charge of men and each of
the seven translations from different
respected translators of the Koran speak
about husband's having the right to
under circumstances of defiance and
arrogance beat their wives do you agree
or disagree with both men ruling over
women in the surah and the permission to
beat them as set forth in the surah I
certainly disagree with the translation
because the Watauga moon in Arabic means
maintain us and protect us and this
world time I am Puma literally means the
stander and that's why you'll find that
the majority of translators translate
like that as for the verse that talks
about the lava which they are required
almost there is a consensus among the
scholars of Islam this is not to be in
vengeful or attacking or harmful or
hurtful action this is talking about
something which is symbolic and the
evidence of that is salami said later on
that you cannot harm or reciprocate hump
so I think there is a problem here with
the understanding of the verse and also
the Prophet said let totally poem Allah
don't hit the women slaves of Allah
meaning women and he says the worst of
you are those who hear the women and
that's why I think if you look at the
totality of evidence then there is a bit
more nuance than you think
Muhammad you quoted the Quran a lot
tonight let me ask you why is the Quran
a more credible final revelation of God
having been dictated to the Prophet by
the angel Gabriel then the Book of
Mormon as the final revelation of God
having been dictated in the 19th century
in upstate New York by the angel Moroni
to the Prophet Joseph Smith the reason
why is because the Quran has certain
parameters and certain challenges that
the Book of Mormon doesn't have for
example as the inevitability challenge
it has the preservation challenge the
Quran is the only preserved book as
predictions that predict the future
that couldn't have been no another time
on probability we find it very difficult
I explained that in the conclusion well
if you wanna give you more expansion of
what I'm saying the Quran has a language
that completely discos or discs of the
Arabic language of the people of the
time and it was recognized by those
linguists is something which was
extraordinary the Quran has a structural
feature that even Orientalist scholars
like Raymond Ferran have looked at and
said that this is something which cannot
be possible considering the
circumstantial revelation of the Quran
so there's many reasons and I think the
main point is that Perron gives us a
falsification challenge and since your
final science the fact that it gives us
a falsification challenge makes it in
many ways quite scientific Mohammed you
have many times embraced what we would
call the Kalam cosmological argument the
first cause argument if in fact time and
space began with the Big Bang and if
something cannot come from nothing but
God created Allah created the world ex
nihilo out of nothing how did an
immaterial being with no physical
attributes no physical brain or body
create everything around us in a context
where there was no time and space for a
to cause B how did he do it how did what
was the mechanism by which this
immaterial being without time and space
created time and space and matter
well as Arab say other than delete laces
allow Adam so ignorance if we don't know
how something works it doesn't mean it
is false however having said that there
is no agreement among Muslims that the
universe was created X neither so there
were some people like Al has early and
others who did believe this what other
people I couldn't tell me I believe that
God perpetually created different things
pretty eternally so once again there is
a scope of interpretation in the Islamic
texts either way the point is causation
doesn't even factor in it because cause
of course is something which brings rise
to phenomenon whereas dependency is
something which is relying on something
else so time or no time whether you
believe in the a theory of time or the B
theory of time you still have to reckon
you have to deal with the fact that you
have things which rely
on each other and if we complied all the
things which rely upon each other
together you would have no existence so
you have to have an independent so the
contingency argument does not rely upon
causality which is why to be frank with
you I didn't make thank you so much that
concludes the cross rapid-fire question
portion of the debate the last portion
of the debate will be the audience Q&A
I'll quickly give an overview of how
this is supposed to work I have three
questions here for Muhammad three
questions here for Edward one for both
of you
I will ask the question whoever it is
directed towards will have two minutes
to respond and then two minutes will be
given to the other person to also
respond presenting their own
perspectives so with that I will begin
with the first question okay before I do
that I have a request if people can
actually not use the Wi-Fi I think we
have too many people and it's crashing
the livestream so if you guys have data
Verizon is great right okay
all right so we'll begin the first
question is directed towards Mohammed
why would God not show himself when he
knows the controversy that goes to
everyone's mind well it's a good
question thank you very much the
question has an empiricist
presupposition which is that in fact
knowledge should be known through the
five senses well as we've discovered
today that's not actually the case so
things like the logic or the the logic
through which science is done was
actually based on metaphysical logical
principles time is not seen mathematics
is not based on science there are lots
of things which are felt which are which
are found out without the empirical
method so the this empirical
naturalistic presupposition is rejected
and if we look at the development of
philosophy in the 20th century we'll
find that even people like aja ax who
wrote a book on positivism he admits to
some of these things and he capitulates
intellectually to these points so Frank
I'll say to you is that in the answer
the question is flawed is based on an
empiricist presupposition which would
mean by extension that science itself
couldn't exist because it's based on
presuppositions which are unscientific
otherwise on thank you the issue is
there are things like logic and
mathematics where the very working out
of the theorems show you the
truthfulness or falsity
however the question of whether God
exists or not is a factual question and
thus makes it subject to an empirical
investigation whether there is such an
all powerful being in the universe is a
factual question akin to whether space
aliens have visited us whether in fact
we do live after death or not when it
comes to questions of fact the empirical
method does apply but there's another
problem here in that both the Bible and
the Quran unmistakably promised eternal
punishment for non belief as a matter of
fundamental fairness we can say that it
is unfair of God to punish us for not
believing in him if he withholds
evidence that would enable us to believe
in him and that's the argument from
divine hiddenness so the laws of logic
and mathematics don't have causative
properties so you can't say the number
seven as an abstraction causes something
to happen but you can say and they do
say as Muhammad does God does cause
things to happen and if an agent has
causative powers and can make or break
something that subject to empirical
investigation thank you both a second
question this is directed towards you
Edward why are a pious --tz-- focused on
a god that would service any God would
not function to offer us what we want
what so the question is basically if a
God exists why are why are idiots so
focused on the fact that a god like that
would serve
us because God Himself is transcendent
and he would not necessarily function to
offer us what we want okay the question
though has a problem and that's that if
you accept an abstract deity that has
not claimed to have been revealed to
humanity then it's understandable that
God would not tailor the evidence to
meet our needs but if a God has
supposedly given us a number of
revelations a Bible Quran Book of Mormon
whatever else then we have a right to
use our reason to expect that such a God
is intending to reveal itself to us and
the failure of that God to fill in the
gaps of the revelation or the failure of
that God to provide us with a reliable
revelation makes non-belief reasonable
if non belief is reasonable it's in
culpable and we are not blameworthy for
non belief because we weren't given
sufficient evidence if we are not
blameworthy for non belief then it's
unfair to punish us for not believing
what we didn't have sufficient evidence
to believe and if we are punished for
not believing what we didn't have
sufficient evidence to believe then that
calls God's moral perfection into
question because we are being punished
on the premise is true and what the
saying is absolutely correct in fact if
God doesn't reveal himself to you and
then punishes you as a result this is
unjust and that's why the Quran says
while my own my davina had Tanabata a
surah chapter 17 verse 15 that we were
not gonna punish them until we sent him
a messenger so scholars of Islam said
even if you die in atheist or a Hindu or
a Christian and even though you're born
with this philtrum with this
predisposition which wasn't
hopefully you'll talk about it this
predisposition to believe in God which
we have evidence for now even though all
of that is in place God will still not
punish those individuals until they're
given sufficient exposure and that is
exactly correct I think you're right
thank you
the next question is directed towards
Mohammed so it's basically the case of
bad design in science there is a concept
of the sterile futures futures that are
a hindrance or otherwise less than
perfect and many organisms if the
universe runs without inconsistency what
would explain the studio futures and the
particular example that was given is the
woman's pelvis which is far too small
and creates a very difficult and painful
birthing process well I think this is
called the argument of ignorance just
because you don't know the function of
something it doesn't mean this function
of this so for example we don't know
what the appendix does it doesn't mean
it has no function it just means we
haven't discovered that yet we don't
know why two electrons can be in one
place at the same time on quantum
mechanics it doesn't mean that's a false
notion even though it goes against the
rules of logic and it goes against some
of the things conventions that we
believe in so just because you don't
know something it doesn't make it false
so that's the first point as for the
second point of bad design I mean who's
the judge of bad design I mean at least
with the fine-tuning argument you have
some kind of probability mathematical
probability that can be attached to this
kind of equation you're saying that the
chances of there not being you know a
universe or the universe having a
non-life permitting rate range is X
which is a mathematical kind of
rendering so here we have to be kind of
honest here and say that this is an
aesthetic value judgment at best
and aesthetic value judgments are not
our opinions frankly your opinion if you
see something that's bad design that's
your opinion you might think it's bad
design but there might be a reason now
there's one more thing I wanna ask cuz
i've got a minute left I think people
have misunderstood my honest my argument
from uniformity I'll add it to the
conclusion like my good friend for us
the hobby mentioned one time in a
podcast I had done with him for example
let's take a coin if we flip a coin it
can either be heads or tails today
we can flip it it's either gonna be
heads or tails tomorrow is going to be
either heads or tails we don't expect
the coin to be flipped and turned into a
butterfly why because we accept that
there's a kind of coherence that exists
throughout kind of constants that exist
so in order to do science you need to
know or you need to presuppose
that this uniformity exists otherwise
your calculations today will be
meaningless tomorrow and that's why
Albert Einstein said that a priori we
expect a chaotic universe meaning from
the mind we expect there not to be this
kind of order so this underpins or is
even more undercutting if you like than
the fine-tuning argument which is why I
presented it so that's that's it thank
you the problem is that when you posit a
god who is supposed to be all-powerful
and morally perfect then defects in our
design are not justified based on those
attributes of God for instance I pointed
out how the gene that can help fight
malaria can also cause sickle cell
anemia we know that we humans have back
problems because we stood up too soon we
know that there are defects in our
bodies we could be more resistant to
cancer we could be more resistant to
viruses we could have a better digestive
system so God cannot get off the hook
here because he is presented as an
all-powerful being who is morally
perfect an all-powerful being who is
morally perfect doesn't make these
missteps in design and we already know
our vulnerability to disease for
instance we already know that we just
have a very few decades to be in good
condition and then as we get older we
begin to decline and so that's not
something that we would expect from a
morally perfect God we wouldn't expect
unnecessary pain if God wants us to take
our hand off the fire so we don't get
burned we would expect pain but if we're
trapped in a burning forest and
burned to death painfully pain has no
value and we wouldn't expect that
unnecessary suffering with no purpose on
theism it's more likely on atheism so
given the claims of God's moral
perfection and omnipotence a defects in
design are not defensible God what proof
do you personally need to believe and
how we say this is the difference
between me and a religious person I'm
subject to evidence religions don't
change regardless of the evidence but an
empirically minded atheist like me would
if right now Mohamed and I were
levitated to the ceiling if my father
who was dead for 18 years walked in this
room right now in his inimitable leader
Shack sent and I recognized him asking
me why not in my office working and then
floated in the air and and and and said
both of you Mormonism is the true
religion if Mohammed and I right now
were teleported to Mecca and I saw the
most amazing astronomical displays
telling me to become a Muslim right away
I would now you might say well this is
the result of an advanced space alien
but being an evidential 'us I would
believe it's a supernatural being
until someone showed me that it was
advanced space aliens so the difference
between atheists like me and those who
subscribe to religion is we are open to
changing if we have direct evidence
whereas there very few religious people
who would say if this happened I would
not believe in God whereas atheists like
me can clearly say if the following
things happen I will believe in God but
we all know they won't happen but if
they did I would answer yes away you get
two minutes we yeah the first point or
not being religious is the pipe that
depends on how you define religion
because frankly if you take it like an
Emile Durkheim approach whose
sociologists he defined religion and
more broad terms than would be found in
vernacular vernacular lien dictionaries
for example which has to be through God
or whatever frankly you could make the
argument that atheist people are very
religious in so much as they have axioms
and they have leaps of faith which they
believe in for instance if we take for
example science science and especially
something like quantum physics you don't
do the experiments yourself you rely
upon witness testimony you don't go into
laboratory and repeat experiments X
amount of times in order to believe it
so in order for you to have an
understanding of science you have to
have a leap of faith in trusting those
individuals who teach you about science
your teachers your schoolbooks and so on
I mean you believe in equality and once
again these are precepts which frankly
are axiomatic meaning they don't have
any evidence to substantiate them even
John Locke who is the founder of
liberalism he based it on God by the way
and that's why you're in the position of
independence created beings as being
referred to over and over again so
really do not have a right up estimate
right school to talk about equality
without having some kind of leap of
faith frankly in those things so
atheists have faith all the time they
have faith in things they don't see they
have faith in things they don't interact
with and what I'm gonna say is that this
is where as John Gray said some people
can wrap a you know discussion of
ideology in sociological format and make
it seem as if it's a religious but in
fact it is actually in terms of its
conventions and epistemic way the same
as any kind of religious belief as for
levitating and so on well you believe in
their levitating but it just has to
happen in the quantum physics realm
where things do levitate and things do
flow Harry Potter exists in the quantum
physics world but an atheist would never
believe it unless a scientist told them
that's belief does faith
thank you an expression to Muhammad what
God riders with autonomy and does that
engage the good and evil argument to
give you what God provide us was
autonomy our free will and does that
negate the gern and evil argument yes so
on Islamic traditionalism God has
endowed us with equal hell or the idea
of choice and free will and in fact even
is a necessary part of that because if
you don't have evil you cannot make a
decision there will just be good and
good to decide from you can't decide
from good and good they have to be good
and bad and therefore you must be tested
even a test makes no sense with the
existence with the non-existence of evil
a tests makes no sense with the
non-existence of evil so sometimes the
bad thing can be good for you well
assets a crochet a whole lot on the
Quran says you could hate something but
it's actually very good for you and the
thing is on theism on Islamic theism we
believe in another domain it's a
metaphysical domain which is young p.m.
the day of judgment whereby one of those
things that we are wronged in in the
dunya the worldly life you'll be
recompensed for that so we don't believe
that when a child dies that's just a
random rearrangement of atoms as would
be the case by the way or naturalism so
random rearrangement of atoms if I slap
a snowman and unlock his head off is the
same is if I cut a kid's head off
because it's just on naturalism frankly
it's just you know a rearrangement of
atoms and in order for you to make any
sense of that you'd have to impose a
subjective value judgment on it which
you'd have to have faith in order to
have in the first place so frankly I
mean what we believe is that the
injustice is of this world Hitler for
example was a very unjust man killed six
million individuals he will be punished
hopefully perpetually in a domain where
in which the punishment is not limited
justice cannot be done on naturalism it
can only be done on a kind of system a
metaphysical system which the undoes all
of the wrongs that happened in this
world
we may not like the implications of a
godless world but that doesn't mean that
a God will come into existence just to
rescue us from those implications we may
not like the fact that we end at death
but that doesn't mean that God will come
about just so that we don't end at death
of that God doesn't otherwise exist the
concept of free will is given more
credit than it deserves if you have two
children
you don't let one of your children push
the other off a cliff just so as not to
interfere in free will
and so the question of free will or even
the benefits of it do not justify the
extreme pain and the extreme suffering
that we undergo so for instance if we
need to feel pain we put our hand on a
hot stove that's understandable but that
pain does not serve a useful purpose if
we are being innocently burnt by evil
people and we have to suffer that
agonizing death so the fact that there
is gratuitous unnecessary unexplained
horrendous suffering goes way beyond
necessary slight evils and suffering
which would have a beneficial and
corrective purpose so we can't say that
any amount of suffering or any amount of
horrible experience is justified because
we need that in which to distinguish the
good even a small amount of evil or a
bearable amount of evil is enough to
distinguish the good it is the presence
of unexplained gratuitous horrendous
suffering that is incompatible with an
all good and all-powerful God thank you
last question directed towards Edward to
summarize essentially Islam provides
objective morality do you believe there
is such a thing
as objective morality and if so how
would you explain why a theists 30 years
ago would object to say homosexuality
well I believe that there are objective
moral values and they're not prescribed
by anybody there is no lawgiver now I
was just asked thirty years ago how
atheists would have responded to
homosexuality this actually proves my
point thirty years ago many atheists may
not have recognized the importance of
allowing such personal freedom what that
means is not that anybody who condemned
persons who love those of the same
gender were right or wrong then it meant
that we hadn't yet discovered the truth
that these are people that deserve equal
rights so for instance in the 1950s when
I was growing up people would be
arrested for being gay they would be put
in prison for being gay the fact that we
don't do that now and it's been illegal
to do so in any state since 2003 shows
that the more we evolve the more we
discover these moral truths not that
somebody invents them and imposes us on
them that by our natural development we
discover these truths for instance it
used to be that religious people would
burn women accused of being witches but
we don't do that anymore because we
discovered the moral truth that it's
wrong to do that to these women
irrespective of the Bible saying thou
shalt not suffer a witch to live so the
more we get away from religious
fundamentalist edicts the more moral and
tolerant we become which shows that
morality cannot be dependent on
religious fundamentalist or Orthodox
edicts because it is our pulling away
from them that makes us more moral more
compassionate and more tolerant
the American founding fathers had used
in order to form at least some period of
time allow slavery graces slavery and
what Stalin used in order to do what he
did what Hitler used frankly to do what
he did this is not the work of religion
this is the work of people who use
ideological justification in order to
commit certain acts the same way is
which something is conceivable to think
that some religious people will use
religious justification in orders commit
certain acts so I don't think there
should be an epistemic preferencing of
one one thing over another here I think
we should just realize that epistemology
drives us to certain forces certain
things and you can't really say more
religion is better than non religion
once again that would depend on how you
define religion in the first place but
having said all of that I mean we've
talked a lot about gay rights today and
all those things but on the harm
principle which is what John Stuart Mill
proposed part of social social
liberalism that you can do whatever you
want so long as you don't harm anyone
else well frankly that would entail that
sex between a brother and sister or
brother and a brother so long as this
couldn't reception news and there's no
deformed babies that should be allowed
as well and I haven't seen anyone doing
incest right activism in America for a
very long time and frankly on liberalism
that's what you should do you know just
because there are minority group of
people that are still in the closet in
the incest closet it doesn't mean now
that they should be treated any less on
liberalism so I think we have to be we
have to be completely honest with
ourselves in our social analysis and if
what we're doing is selecting certain
social things which have become popular
early 21st century to make a case about
God's existence and I think really we're
being academically disingenuous so I
think at the end of the day whatever
principle you're going to have you have
to apply it across the board and if it
is the hum principle and social
liberalism then incest should be allowed
in this country and people should be
able to do that
thank you final question this is
directed to both of you
Edward because you began I'll start with
Mohammed please address the viability of
Pascal's wager well I mean Pascal is
kind of like it's not really an argument
to be honest with you which is why them
kind of make ace Pascal was a famous
mathematician who talked about you know
basically making a wager you know
betting on the fact that going god
exists because the because doing
otherwise may mean that you know you'll
you'll you'll die and go to hell and so
on and so therefore what makes sense to
do that what we're saying is that fair
enough there is some truth in that I
mean if you think about the Quran
actually affirms some of that where it
says you know well in Kenema no angel
appear in the LA he's so much a B
what if it was from God what if this was
from God and you are disbelieving in it
so it's a for experiment right it's more
of a thought experiment rather than an
arguments I think the maximum we can do
with it is you have a thought experiment
make people think about death you know
make people think about the fact that
they're going to die and what kind of
ideology or what kind of belief system
they want to have would then one day in
their graves frankly because atheism
will not do anything as a matter of fact
now I'm not saying therefore God exists
because that's not an argument I've made
that clear it's not an argument to say
well the implications of atheism is that
you know you're going to be in the sick
bed you're gonna be maybe 75 years old
one and two people in United States of
America are gonna have cancer just like
in the UK put into cancer research and
what is better for you I mean as it to
be optimistic that there's going to be
continuation of that life or to know
that actually you're going to just
become bones and dust obviously from an
implications perspective theism and
especially theism with afterlife
implications has better employed
optimistic implications for you your
memories will be wiped away your
experiences will be wiped away and your
bodies will be wiped away
that's atheist naturalism but the
implications of of theism is that
actually there will be continuations
that's just the beginning and so this is
not an argument why it is an implication
well there is a problem with Pascal's
wager
now Mohammed just admitted that the
Quran does talk about punishment and
hell for not believing in Islam as the
Bible talks about punishment and Hell
for not believing in Christianity what
Pascal's wager did was it made the error
of automatically assuming that if there
is a God this being will judge us by how
we worship this being rather than how
good we are to each other and so the
wager actually is false because it
presupposes without proof that God is
such an evil being if there is a God
that regardless of how good we are
unless we adopt the right religion we
will burn in hell forever now I'm sure
that Pascal who was a Christian would
not have accepted that someone is
meeting the wager if they were Muslim
and I think that the defect is whenever
we say without any evidence whatsoever
other than ancient hearsay in ancient
books which we know were written by
fallible men as women weren't even
involved in the writing of these books
when we say we are certain that the
ultimate force in the universe will
punish you unless you adopt my religion
that is nothing but primitive
exclusivism I think we got one more girl
thank you vote that concludes our
audience Q&A we will now proceed to the
closing statements each person will have
15 minutes to give theirs and we will
begin with
fifteen
that's done
all right please come down 15 minutes
left and then we finish I'll start
witness quite someone expired
just so quickly I'm saying now just to
quickly kind of comment on the last
thing that it talked about ancient
hearsay and so on democracy is an
ancient concept liberalism is an ancient
concept it's still it's still adopted by
you know mainstream society that's the
genetic fallacy basically to criticize
something based on where it came from
anyway I found quite interesting in the
last speech that Eddie Edward had he
actually made an interesting
capitulation he admitted that 99% of
things natural science can explain that
means 1% of things are supernatural that
means miracles are possible so that is
very happy all right
secondly now what you talked about about
cause and effect now the definition of a
cause is something which brings rise to
phenomena I can cause a house to be for
example I can build a house yes I can
build a house but I can die and the
house will continue to be yes so I don't
need to exist in order for the house to
continue existing dependence on the
other hand is when you rely on something
else so he made the mistake of saying
that contingency which is dependence
relies upon cause and effect
it doesn't which is why I didn't really
mention cause an effect to avoid this
discussion altogether let us agree for
the same imbalance okay
let's agree that there's no such thing
as cause methane's the contingency
argument the way I framed it is still
valid because I didn't mention cause and
effect at all let me tell you why
interesting atheists when he was because
a logical are given the hassanis
argument that William Lane Craig and
those other guys are making popular now
in this country so has that is argument
everything that begins to exist has a
course the universe began to exist
therefore the universe has a cause
okay so Bertrand Russell said but this
is the problem of composition because
you're saying that just because there
are causes in the universe it doesn't
mean that
cause we'll be applied to the universe
so he says for example just because we
have mothers as part of the human race
it doesn't mean that the human race
itself has mother imagine a war like
Trump likes wolf yeah just because this
is Bertrand Russell is a very valid
argument he says just because the world
is made up of small parts it doesn't
mean that the world itself is small he's
right
Bertrand Russell was right however what
if the world is made up of red paths the
morning stuff can be read so the fallacy
of composition is a double-edged sword
because in order for it to be a proper
fallacy it needs to have perfect
knowledge of the whole if you don't have
perfect knowledge of the whole you can't
claim it to be a fallacy
so both the theists and the Atheist are
in a good line because the Atheist is a
well it can't be the small part can't be
the me but the fiercest same or the red
part can make red bricks can make a red
wall and both can be possible but both
both can be argued against you see so
this is why I use the contingency
argument
let me bring back the on Linda I use
causation for the sake of argument no
problem you can have causation let's
pretend you know there's no let's
pretend it's possible that it can exist
and it's possible they can't ask for the
universe on logical basis however
contingency dependents I made an
ontological arguments a mathematical
argument says yes now you can't have the
existence of things if everything else
if existence depends upon dependent
things existence would never exist you
have to either independent outside or
the independent this series
and what is it necessary independent
however as different yes and we said a
possible existence is something which
can be rearranged I'm not going to be
really great here today I know you're
used to this I you season is debated
William Lane Craig this is his argument
I know the weaknesses of the argument I
didn't use this argument I want the most
undercutting argument
no one can crack this argument I've read
from Plato to live lives all the way
through to Russell and believe me this
is the argument no one can solve this is
the uncrackable code so he tried to
crack the code by saying well the
necessary existence should be what I'm
saying they're complete opposite I'm
saying that it's impossible for it to be
made up of parts and still be the
necessary existence because a possible
existence is an existence that is
subject to change so to use this
phraseology if we look at the weight of
the evidence the totality of the
evidence where extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence
we have an extrude we have an absolutely
extraordinary evidence
which works in the mind mathematically
and works in physical reality
cosmologically and works on first
principles and we get the independent
self-sufficient one entity which we as
Muslims call Allah that's it what if
there's a multiverse
well if there's a multiverse no problem
have a multiple an infinite amount of
universes or more even just universes
because why discriminate to order
universes creations upon those things
and we said it can't be that because you
can envisage taking a universe in and
out and so it's dependent upon the
structure it's over
you see here it's important to be honest
with ourselves he's a lawyer a lot of
lawyers I referred to as liars but he's
not one of them he's a good man and as a
lawyer when he goes into the the
courtroom he refers to witness testimony
he makes abductive arguments like CSI
CSI forensics put the evidences together
it's not god of the gaps just in the
same ways if you put food for a dog and
then you go away and that and the food
is eaten you're not going to say that's
a dog of the gapps argument it's just an
abductive inference which he does every
time and if it's not that if you don't
do an abductive inference then all of
the cases he's represented have been
miscarriages of justice which I'm sure
he wouldn't do and the point here is
this the point is when we put the
totality of evidence asking for more
evidence you know it's like when we've
given you ontological metaphysical April
I write a post all right scientific
physical mathematic probabilistic
evidences it's like asking for a torch
when you're in the middle of daylight
give me a torch but why do you need to
talk to my friend everything around you
you're locked into the arguments
everywhere you go there's an arguments
there's evidence there's science even to
the extent whereby even to the extent
whereby you're born with that feeling of
believing in God and then you have to
socially construct according to Justin
barek
others your atheism just like you use
other social constructed ideas like
second wave feminism liberalism I don't
think people don't know about liberalism
were women by the way you're talking
about what about these men don't all men
liberalism is written by men John Locke
John Stuart Mill Russo wants us to
Thomas Hobbes I don't hear I don't see
any woman's names there so frankly let's
not play these games what I will say is
this what I will say is as Muslims we
have additional evidence and this is the
evidence from revelation the Koran says
a woolly bedroom three Admiral up woman
badly Halloween saleable that the Romans
had been defeated Lord black neighbor
Island and after that defeat they will
become victorious
it makes predictions which materialize
and look at this just as one piece of
evidence and you can look at my videos
for more but it's just one thing when
someone makes a succession of
predictions of the future why is the
probability that some of those
predictions will be false if you add all
of those things and you aggregate them
in your total probability chart and you
ask the question if someone makes all of
these if someone makes all of these
predictions of the future like the Quran
does what's the probability that this
could have been I guess well there's a
way of finding that out through
mathematical probability theory for
example or historic probability so
frankly we do have an argument it's not
and by the way there's something else
here very important he made a good point
he made a very good point
he said that why is it the case that
miracles are confined or time bound he's
right for a Christian that would be a
great argument if you say to a Christian
how comes Jesus rested dead when we
couldn't see it absolutely right mother
well the colossal model selected like
have fattened in se we have not sent you
to except for to Muhammad all of
humankind
the reason why those prophetic miracles
were localized like Jesus or Moses plain
to see whoever may be is because they
appealed or is meant to appeal to that
time and that people as for the Quran
itself it claims to be the miracle it's
an another Torah miracle so that you can
analyze it in any time in any place so
it's not giving an unfair advantage to
the primary audience you can try and
falsify the Quran now that gives you a
way to try and do so you can try and
imitate the Quran now challenges are the
challenges you to do so and you can try
and look at those things in the Quran
which claim to be happening in the
future and analyze whether they did in
hindsight now because we have seen
whether it happened or not for example
these are some examples now in the last
two or three minutes I want to say
something important putting this
discussion to the side you know Edward
is one of our friends here in America
and the reason why I'm putting this in
the end is because I've kind of finished
everything and I wanted to say this
he works actively to promote the rights
of Muslims in this country and its
people like Edwards that allow for
Muslims in this country and in the West
to be able to be guaranteed the same
kind of freedoms frankly that other
every other person should happen I
believe that if you're going to believe
in something be consistent with it and
though maybe not in the field of atheism
and God's existence you might not be
fully consistent but in his morality
he's a man of consistency he opposes
Trump's ban on Muslims he's a friend of
the Muslims and what I want to end off
by saying here is this is the kind of
person who were happy to have them as a
friend of the Muslim community here in
the USA
honestly after things like the
Christchurch Massacre or other terrorist
attacks happening on both sides bad
things are happening we need to be able
to build bridges
I believe Edward is the man or the kind
of person Edward is is the kind of
person we need to be friends with we
need to invite to our houses we need to
be kind to we need to show courtesy to
and we to respect highly despite
religious or ideological disagreements
we will agree to disagree but we will
also agree to agree where our interests
are mutual and where we can oppose a
common threat to both of our existences
Edward is consistent because he does not
like arbitrariness which is a which is a
theme in liberalism where one community
are not treated the same as another
community it is a law and you believe in
liberalism let that law be applied to
everyone and he has done some great work
he has done some great work opposing
arbitrary kinds of judgments that have
happened in different states and he was
telling me about that and really and
truly we take our hats off to him and
his and people like
finally finally I want to say in my last
half a minute left that if I suddenly
need to offend anyone here that I
apologize that that was not my intention
and that obviously this is a subject
which we really feel passionate about
and as a superior to me in knowledge and
experience
I want to thank from the bottom of my
heart
Edwards contribution to today's
discussion it's been edifying it's been
brilliant for me and I'm sure it's been
fantastic for you you're welcome at
anytime I'm sure I can say that on
behalf of this for the University and
hopefully we can meet another day thank
you very much
[Applause]
well thank you Mohammed the issue that
Mohammed raises again pinning his
argument on the concept of unnecessary
being remember the problem with that is
the problem is that a necessary fact
cannot explain a contingent fact without
introducing a new contingent fact in
need of explanation and to see why
notice that a necessary fact cannot
explain a contingent fact by entailing
it because then any fact entailed by a
necessary fact must itself to be
necessary and this sets up the
regression all the way back into the
past which Muhammad is trying to avoid
now with respect to my comment that 99%
of all scientific discoveries will show
to be natural that doesn't mean the 1
percent will be supernatural it means
the opposite it means the likelihood of
anything being supernatural is very
implausible and the way I said it was
that unless something appears miraculous
like the Stars rearranging themselves
telling us what to do it is a God of the
gaps argument as far as the qur'an's
prediction is concerned both the Quran
and the Bible have failed to make the
kinds of pure predictions which would
show the supernatural now with respect
to the Quran it was finished in 632 but
it was not codified into a final written
form until 2018 years later in 650 by
the caliph Uthman and now the only
earliest version we have of a 90%
complete Quranic text is from the mid
eight century
which could be almost 80 years after the
Quran was initially given to Muhammad
now another problem is with respect to
translations every time I point out
something to Muhammad about the
translations that I have before me even
eight or nine of them his responses he
disagrees with the translation I don't
necessarily disagree that Muhammad might
understand the Quran in the original
Arabic far better than all these
translations my argument is from divine
hiddenness if the Quran is God's
ultimate revelation to humanity it is
inconsistent with that purpose for us
who speak only English not to have a
reliable translation of Muhammad was not
able to demonstrate how an immaterial
incorporeal being created time and space
see what Muhammad was trying to do as a
valiant attempt was to rescue was to
rescue some vestige of the supernatural
from a purely natural universe and
ultimately it was unsuccessful he was
not able to refute at all my argument
from evolution he did not refute my
argument from evil he was not able to
explain how an all-powerful God that can
prevent a lot of evil still has to allow
so much evil he did not adequately
refute my argument from divine
hiddenness because he was not able to
give a reason why a God who wants us to
know his will would withhold the very
evidence that we need to be able to
believe in that God I as an atheist gave
you clear examples of the type of
miraculous occurrences which would make
me turn into a believer in fact if my
dead father appeared right now
transported Muhammad and
me to Mecca and told me and I knew it
was my dad that since dying he realized
that Islam was the perfect religion
I would convert right away so I'm
subject to an open to the evidence the
other thing that Muhammad did not refute
was my claim that the Quran liked the
Bible the Quran like the Bible demands
eternal punishment for choosing the
wrong religion I believe that we human
beings have a right to use our reason
and sense of justice to say that it is
wrong for any all-powerful deity to
condemn innocent people to eternal
suffering because of an honest mistake
in choosing the wrong religion and so I
believe to that extent the Bible and the
Quran are equally equally false however
I have to say the Quran did improve on
the Bible in one area if you read
Jeremiah 99 you see that God threatens
to make people eat their sons and
daughters
in the Quran there's no such vestige of
cannibalism so if God does exist I thank
him for in-between the Bible and the
Quran taking human flesh off the menu
the
[Applause]
Mohammed was unable to refute the
argument against a transcendental person
because if you are a person you have to
have some boundaries some limit to say
that you are not in time and space and
you are in time and space what are we
talking about like some guy standing up
waist-deep in a hot tub he's half in and
half out how can you be partially in
time how can God enter time in order to
enter time you have to have a beginning
in time a timeless being cannot do
anything either can an immaterial being
now I know that the concept that death
is the end is very difficult for most
people to tolerate but on atheism what's
true is not what we would like to be
true what's true is what cold hard
reality shows is true there is no
example whatsoever of conscious
self-awareness being able to exist
without a fully functional physical
brain if it were so then Alzheimer's
disease would not be able to eclipse
consciousness again Alzheimer's disease
eclipses your consciousness but when you
die you're fully intact in an immaterial
form it can't happen that way also the
argument from evolution with the common
ancestry that we have with apes we
didn't evolve from apes but we spun
often had a common ancestor if you look
at the fossil record of the precursors
to homo sapiens who we are now
you see we evolved from a more primitive
life-form both the Bible and the Koran
accept the notion of Adam and Eve you
can't have an Adam and Eve if evolution
is true which it is because there was no
such thing as the first perfect human
couple we evolved like any other
creature so if there was no Adam and Eve
both the Bible and the Quran are wrong
in saying that there
and of course if there was no Adam and
Eve then Christianity is completely
wrong in talking about the sin in the
Garden of Eden now another thing that
Muhammad was unable to do was to
demonstrate and I've seen other Muslim
apologists try to do this was to
demonstrate that the language or the
mode of Arabic itself used in the Quran
had to have a divine authorship you can
have advanced language or poetic or
useful verse or you can make innovations
in language but that does not show that
there was a supernatural origin also he
failed to show us what specific
predictions in the Quran took were made
that turned out to be true on one of his
YouTube videos he talks about a Roman
war which the Quran predicted the Romans
would lose well I looked it up that war
ended in 628 seee and the Quran was
finished in 632 CE II so the Quran did
not predict anything in the future the
other aspect of all of this is the
incompatible properties of the concept
of God the very concept of God God
cannot be both omnipotent and omniscient
if God is omnipotent
it means God can do anything including
change his mind but if God is omniscient
he always knew what he was going to do
in the very end so he cannot change his
mind
so therefore the properties of
omniscience and omnipotence are
incompatible with respect to the
fine-tuning argument that sort of
Mohammed flirted with and then moved
away from if we look at that on theism
you would not need any kind of
fine-tuning because God would be capable
of making us live
in any environment so the whole notion
of fine tuning is nonsensical but yet if
you look at a theism and there is no
all-powerful God who could make us live
in any environment then we wouldn't then
we would need fine-tuning because there
is no supernatural being to sustain us
any which way which makes fine-tuning
curiously more likely on atheism now
I've heard Muslim apologists say that
the Quran predicted that the universe is
expanding I looked at four different
translations and the only one that used
the term expanding there was Mustapha
kitab in 2016 the three other
translations including the classic
Pickthall and abdullah yusuf ali all of
them had the vastness of space already
existing so if the Quran did predict
that the universe is expanding which
meant that the Quran had divine
foreknowledge before science that the
Big Bang occurred then only one out of
four translations shouldn't be able to
show that so once again on divine
hiddenness if the Quran is what God
wants me to believe then the Quran
should have been translated into ink
true also on the argument from evil and
I've touched upon this is the
distribution of pleasure and pain on
theism we would expect that horrendous
pain would only exist if there's a
purpose that would aid our survival or
our reproduction so if I put my hand on
the hot stove it's hurt so I take my
hand away but let's say again I or some
innocent animal are caught in a forest
fire and were unable to pull away from
the pain and we suffer a horrible death
well the pain of that burning to death
did not contribute to my survival or
reproduction and so on atheism it's
understandable on theism it's it's not
understandable I referred earlier to the
Bayesian probability analysis on
Bayesian probability analysis which is
widely used you have to have prior
knowledge of something there's no prior
knowledge of the supernatural so if you
use Bayesian confirmation predictive
ability you would not be able to predict
the supernatural
if the supernatural existed there would
be evidence of it if consciousness could
exist without a functional physical
brain there'd be evidence of it if the
Bible or the Quran predicted something
which could only have been known by
miraculous means when it was written
there would be evidence of it if we
humans were specially created there
wouldn't be overwhelming evidence that
we evolved from ape-like creatures from
a common ancestor with apes so with all
of the evidence a cumulative case shows
the universe is natural and not
supernatural and that God does not exist
thank you
[Applause]
and with that comes about we conclude
the debate does that go okay to everyone
for coming out we really appreciate see
you guys again in the future and mail
look Andy everyone give them another
round of applause
[Applause]
I would also like to give a big THANK
YOU to with another key organizer and
his name is object man he did a lot of
this work and I want to give him a
really sweet donations really big and
it's all before everyone leaves
something super important again if
anyone is able to we are really really
asking for donations to help cover costs
for the trip I'm in fur on the event so
if anyone wants to marry the box with
their dates outside there's also some
any moment visit MSA and we appreciate
anything and everything exactly always
for coming everyone and shuttle have a
good day